oh
okay next I'm very pleased to introduce
our speaker today Chen
um Chen Wang serves as a senior research
software engineer RSE at the national
center for the super Computing
applications NCSA of University of
Illinois Urbana-Champaign with a
background in environmental science
holding a BS and Ms degrees in
atmospheric science along with another
Ms in bioenergy Chen's expertise spans
web application development scientific
algorithm implementation and data
analytics she leads the development of
the social media macroscope and has made
significant contributions to projects
like the K-12 School reopening
interactive Playbook during covid
supported by the Rockefeller Foundation
as well as ongoing initiatives including
the NSF funded clouder and nist funded
in core proficient in Python JavaScript
Java and familiar with restful Services
database design container Technologies
and AWS cloud computing Chen is
dedicated to harnessing her extensive
experience to create impactful science
ghetto gateways and research web
applications thereby expanding the
accessibility of value valuable
scientific insights
okay with that I will hand it off to
Chen officially and she will get started
with her presentation
thank you
thanks Olivia for introducing me and
it's my pleasure to be here and to
Showcase this tool we developed called
the social media macroscope
oops sorry technical difficulties
I don't see that on my screen actually
and I don't see it on this very Middle
East
[Music]
oh sorry I got it
rinsed restart
yeah um thank you for being here
um so the social media macroscope is
like actually a suite of tools to help
you make sense of social media data
um this is who we are we're from the
national Center for super Computing
applications
Affiliated to the University of Illinois
at Urbana-Champaign and we also
collaborate with external collaborator
Joe from University of Pittsburgh
um so why social media microscope this
has been a ongoing effort since like
2017.
um when we first started to develop this
uh we look at the landscape of social
media analytics tools and there are a
lot of those but they generally fall
into two categories on one hand you have
those commercial tools have very nice
user interface and very easy to use like
for example
um if you're familiar with Meta Meta has
its own like business analytics
um like tools and in
um and Instagram also have like insights
to help you being like aggregated
um
data points of
um certain like features however
um
how they actually come up with those
metrics and how to gather the data and
how to generate the analytics are all
like a very black boxed a lot of our
users are researchers and from Academia
when they publish their research it's
very hard for them to cite or refer to
those
data generated by those platforms on the
other hand we have like extremely
transparent ways to do your research
which is write your own python or write
your or script there are a lot of
abundance of
open sourced like analytics packages
that you can leverage to scrape the data
to crawl the web to perform like natural
language processing and those kind of
tasks however it is a little bit
it has certain barrier like a researcher
has to have some
programming background to be able to use
on those tools
okay
um so user have to
um have certain training in like have
certain computation background to be
able to use those tools but however a
lot of social media researchers they're
actually coming from a Humanity or like
social science background to ask them to
learn programming from scratch is kind
of distracting them from their job
so we thought about those and like why
can we create something that position
ourselves in the intersection of the
ease of use as well as the transparency
of methodology so here we are yeah
um
or other other benefits for example
right now to use the social media
microscope it's completely free for
academic use versus if you have to use
commercial tools you usually have to pay
thousands of dollars of subscription fee
and we also cater to academic needs so a
lot of our metrics are more research
focused versus those commercial tools
usually are like catering to marketing
or like
um brand like analytics those type of
states and lastly because we're right
next to a research institution so we
have the advantage of directly
incorporate the research results without
waiting for the full cycle of like
publication and then read the
publication and then get the data and
then Trace back to how the data was
generated yeah
so that explains our motivation and so
what is social media microscope so it's
not just one tool it's like a set of
tools that we accumulate like a
portfolio we accumulate over the years
like
um
like an app store yeah so we have three
tools so far and smile is the one I will
talk the most about tonight it is the
one comprehensive platform for social
media data ingestion analysis as well as
data sharing and then we have Bay Bay
stands for brand analytics environment
this is more specific
catering to Brand personality
it can learn a user's tweets and then
compare with a consumer Brand's tweets
and see what's their correlation and
lastly we have this sfm clouder it's a
data management framework developed
in-house at NCSA called clouder but we
can customize it to suit for different
domains so in our case we add a lot of
plugins and features to create a smm
clouder yeah
so this is our past usage data so over
the years this tool has been used a lot
for teaching
um so it has been used for an online MBA
class at UIUC so you can see we have
like our Peak we have like about 4 000
users
um
so now
um I'll share with you a little bit more
about our tool smile so analyze it with
a smile
yeah you can click this link to try it
you shouldn't be able to need to
register anything
and I was gonna give a live demo but
live demo is too tricky so
I recorded
um
yeah and I'll talk along with this
um so if you this is our landing page if
you have any collaborative ideas don't
hesitate to reach out to us
and if we go to get start and this will
lead you to those three tools that we
currently have
and if you click this it will lead you
to smile we name this playground because
this instance is meant for Public Access
so all of your data will be kept only
for one day in a system but along the
way your you can download your data and
so this is the main interface of smile
it's a web application and these are the
features we have
and
when you click get start this is our
paper references
um that you can
you're welcome to cite us to support us
or if you're using our tool to generate
data and you want to publish with that
and feel free to also cite us and now
you can log in we used a plugin called
CI logon which is also developed at NCSA
this thing will allow you to log in with
your own ident your own like institution
identity so we just trust you as who you
say you are we don't actually actively
manage the user database so there are a
lot of options you can select
so here I have University of Illinois if
we uh if you're a public you can also
use Google
um so I'm logging here I'm logging use
the NCSA credential and it will
recognize who I am here
and then the first step is getting data
you can authorize using your own social
media account
so here I'm authorizing using my X slash
Twitter yeah but
Twitter slash X has been giving us a lot
of headache this year since elong has
taken over
um so right now we recommend you to try
the try with Reddit yeah because Reddit
might be smoother
so here I am trying to search some
comments in a given specific Reddit
separated I tried to search comments in
chat GPT subreddit
and it will give me the latest comments
and this is the preview
if you think it looks good then you can
save the data
um
after you save the data
actually let me see if I can full screen
this
um okay
so after you save the data you have
three options you can download the file
and then do your own analysis and you
can also find this if you leave this
page you can find it in the past history
here are some quick visualization that
help you get some insights and you can
see the post frequency by just toggling
between different time intervals and
here is a way after you leave this
interface you can find your passwords
so here this is a previous search I did
and this is the search that I just did
and here you can download and preview
so next is algorithms here are all the
currently supported algorithms
mostly related to
natural language processing and topic
modeling and name entity recognition so
here I will demo two analysis one is
topic modeling
um the first step is here and you can
select all the data you queried using
the smile and you select chat GPT and
then here is the algorithm and some
parameters you can tweak for example you
can decide how many numbers of topic you
want to see them aggregated and then
this is the citation comes along with
the algorithm we use
and then after you run it since it's not
real time it might take a few seconds a
few minutes so you can input your email
address and it will let you know
when it's ready
and when it's ready you'll get an email
and then
you can directly download some of the
output but for a better view you can
follow the instruction and go to your
past results and see this
so this is another python Library we use
called pivis
LDA yeah which I'll talk a little bit
more later this will help you to
um visualize the topic you can do some
basic things you can see different
topics and you can also toggle the
relevance metrics to on the Fly see what
are the words related to this topic
and the next analysis I want to
introduce you is sentiment analysis yeah
so same first step is select your data
and then for sentiment analysis we
actually support three different
algorithms they're all open sourced
we have this Vader and centurnet and the
last one is the
machine learning model trained to help
you detect bias in sentiment and
classification
so here I'm trying Vader because Vader
is the fastest in its life
um after submit this time you
immediately see some results you can tag
it so later you can find them better and
here is a pie chart that shows you the
breakdown of the the sentiment
and here is a data table that you can
click the header and compare and show
the most positive or negative and
yeah along the left here is how you
download
and the last part of this smile demo is
a sneak peek into the second part that I
will talk about about smm clouder this
is a beauty interface to help you port
your data in smile into clouder
so here we log into clouder and just
imagine clouder is like a Google drive
or box that has a rich metadata support
as you can see you can come up with your
own metadata as well as other
customizable visualization and
information extraction process
so by porting the data into
clouder if you want to do more
comprehensive data management kind of
thing so that's our recommendation to do
that
in
here I am going to create a data set and
then these are all the results
associated with this analysis and then I
can click upload and then this now
you're leaving smile you'll go to the
color interface
and this is your data now
um documented in clouder
yep
so here are some highlights of the smile
features
um so this one talks about how we
actually collect the social media data
we actually have a graphql powered data
server sets in between the user
interface the smile server as well as
between all those social media platforms
if you want to know more about graphql
you can click that link to read more
about it if you want to know how we
Implement graphql you can visit our
public GitHub repository by clicking
that link here
um so here are some of the advantages of
using graphql it gives you the the best
part of it is because social media data
are very heterogeneous like
um Twitter will give you one form of the
response and like say Reddit will give
you a completely different shape so by
having a graphql backed data server we
can have one clean API interface for
handling those and we can easily get
predictable results based on what you
queried
um
then oh go ahead yes
two Twitter and Reddit Instagram yes
yeah
um and we try to work with the official
apis
um so we try to behave we don't do like
data like crawling or scraping or those
kind of things
um and next is we try to
follow the standard oauth 2 flow to let
user to get data using their own
credentials if you're curious about
oauth 2 you can click this link
um so the coral smile
um I I would like to say the core of
smile is nothing fancy but a
user-friendly user interface that
encapsulates all those python algorithms
so so far we have six
um different algorithms they're all
written in Python and on top of that we
have a smile server that wrapped around
it so user who doesn't know programming
can still be able to use those
algorithms
um and a few highlights of that is we
try to stay open we Embrace open source
packages and libraries and we try to
stay pythonic because python has um its
extensive selection of Open Source
packages that we can leverage and build
upon some of the examples are we're
using on nltks I could learn Network X
and
Etc yeah and last thing is
um bad analogy but I can't help myself
so I postmarked a table because we're
right next to a research institution we
actually have a lot of direct
collaboration with the researchers so
before they even publish their paper
they are generous enough to hand over us
their algorithms so we can actually
deploy them as a part of the feature so
some of the examples if you see the
automated phrase mining as well as the
name entity technician we get them
directly from the source from the Purdue
produce yeah
so this is our code structure and this
is a little bit boring so I'll fly over
this quickly if you want to learn more
details uh you can click this this is an
example of how we do sentiment and now
how we organize our sample analysis as
you can see a lot of the code here are
generic we have generic classes that
represent different interactions like
how to talk to clouder or how to talk to
a smile server and how we talk to the
webmq messenger broker and how we handle
IO like input and output and those kind
of and visualization and notification
but underneath it we have a specific
implementation of different algorithms
for example this one we have sentiment
analysis
this way we can reuse a lot of the code
to for different purposes for example we
can view the same with the same
selection of files we can build both
containers for cloud extraction or we
can view containers for the SMF for the
smile
and here are some of the Python
libraries that we're leveraging
um so if you're familiar with NLP we use
the popular D platform that for building
Python program work with human language
um
and some of the analysis that use nltk
is on the sentiment analysis our natural
language reprocessing if you click this
link
it will lead you to our public GitHub
repo and you can see our code there
and next is secular we have a basic
implementation of machine learning
featuring smile which basically allow
you to split your data set into training
and prediction and then you can hand
label your training data you train the
model using different using a selection
of
algorithms and then you can do some
basic categorization
um so for this we use the cycle learn
package and next and Jensen is used for
topic modeling and you can read more
about how we do that collect this
example link and passing is a network X
we use that for creation and for
creation of Twitter Network you can
generate a retweet graph or like
mentions graph by using by leveraging
Network X and there are other generic
libraries we use I didn't include we use
a lot of pandas because we claim all
those data into a tabular format so we
actually use pandas to do a lot of the
data manipulation
um next
so for visualization we use a library
called plotly
um it is also a python Library the cool
thing about Bali is
um it is a open source python library
that can make interactive graphs and it
has a lot of out-of-box graph types and
the best part of it is like you're using
python to actually generate front-end
HTML code with JavaScript embedded in
this so as it alleviates the burden of
on your front end to be able to generate
those dynamic graphs and also since it's
the back end we generate that and you
can actually store it into HTML file and
then you can easily share this HTML file
with other people you can just drop this
file to your collaborator and they get
the same exact interactive graph you
have and if you I think they have a paid
feature if you pay pay for the charge
Studio you can also connect this into
that
highlighting emails and in here you can
do more like graph editing it has more
capability that way and for smile this
is our example we summarize we write a
few basic visualization for the pie
chart for the bar chart as well as for
the network chart because we use a lot
in the smile
this slide is listing all the resources
if you're curious you can look at our
repository and it's not nothing from
perfect
yeah it's not very perfect but we
leverage GitHub so if you identify any
features if you want to see or if you
notice any bug feel free to open the
issue and our development team will
address them
and we're working on the documentations
so hopefully we'll have nice
documentation coming up
and this is about deployment
um
and I'll so smile has been a long going
project so it actually goes through
several iterations so on the left is our
past architecture as you can see we
leverage a lot of AWS and we also use
hubzero which is a NSF funded science
Gateway
um
but we're moving towards a more
Standalone independent
design by leveraging
container technology like jocker so each
of the blocks the red box you can see is
its own Docker container and then we use
you can use Docker compose or like
kubernetes
to orchestrate your communication
so this slide just give you a quick uh
introduction on containerization if
you're not familiar with Docker
um I'm not very good at this but I will
try like my analogy is like a Docker is
like a shipping container and inside of
this container it's like a independent
environment that you have everything you
need and you can move your shipping
container anywhere you want to you can
move it to the ship and you can move it
to another ship and it will still be the
same yeah and but this shipping content
this containers are independent of each
other how do we make them talk to each
other on the easiest way is to use
Docker compose it's a lightweight way to
orchestrate multiple Docker containers
and of course it has its own limitation
but I would say that is the easiest
thing to start and we actually publish
our Docker compose script and our goal
is for anyone to be able to run their
own smile or clouder on their
infrastructure so it's like this is like
a recipe and with this recipe and always
the same material we hope that you can
reproduce the same things
and next is kubernetes kubernetes is a
lot more fancier and it's also related
to the whole shipping container like
analogy so kubernetes in Greek means
Helmsman and pilot
so it is a even fancier way to
orchestrate different containers it can
do things like load balancing like if
you know you're experiencing like very
high traffic it it can automate it but
it can be automated to scale up on the
spot yeah so that's kubernetes and next
is how it is still related to those
terminologies yeah Helms is just an easy
way to help you configure kubernetes
because kubernetes is have a very steep
learning curve and have a lot of
configuration courts and Helms is a tool
that provides you a standard template
set by following those templates you can
easily configure a kubernetes cluster so
we also publish our home chart so anyone
who
familiar with this realm should be able
to follow our home chart to start up our
instance
so this slide has all the resources for
how to deploy smile we publish
everything to the docker Hub so every
image should be available and we do
regular release
um and next is this is the instruction
on how you can run Docker compose
and last is how you can run it using
kubernetes
um
next I'm going to talk a little bit
about smile louder you had a sneak peek
of clouder
um so this is like I'll give you more
context
so first of all white clouder
clowder
comparing to all those commercial tools
that like box or way
actually I have a question for you all
so does anyone know what the word cloud
review
okay clouder actually means a group of
cats yeah
so
um it's not one cat it's a group of cat
and so clouder instance is not one
centralized data management tool so it's
actually many instances of this tool so
that differentiates us from Google Drive
or box
so it has this flexible deployment on
the cloud capability so with this
capability we can spend time and spin
off our own Smiles as smm cloud or
instance and and also has all the four
data management management capacity you
can upload download you can share your
data you can set access control on your
data
our next is it has a lot of Rich
metadata support like a lot of
scientific data requires
documentation of like metadata so
clouder and is very good at that and the
last two is the customization capability
you can write your custom information
extractor basically runs when you upload
your file or upload your data or doing
some uh something that triggers those
and it can extract information from the
data from your data and generates a
meaningful like outputs and next is
custom visualization capability so you
can write your own customized
visualization for a very specific
purpose like on your left hand or you
can see this one is for client science
who they write their own preview words
for that so for our smile instance we
heavily leveraging the last two
capabilities
so here
um
we basically
implant like transplant the same
smile algorithms as information
extractor and put it put them inside of
smile
so by doing that now a user have the
flexibility to upload their own source
data if they have their own CSV so they
have their own tabular format of some
natural language data now they can run
the same smile algorithm Within clouder
so this way first of all it's guaranteed
reproducible because it's essentially
the same algorithm and secondly it's
like
bad analogy again
so it's like smile it's like having your
computation
it's moving the data through your
computation but this is moving the
computation right next to your data so
this way you don't need to worry about
like if you have a very large data set
you don't need to worry about the
transferring
and lastly it's an ecosystem clouder has
its own community and over the years
through different domains through
collaborative effort there are a lot of
clouder information extractors available
out there
so you can not only use the smile once
but also you can leverage other
extractors and you can also for the
output of smile you can also do more
post processing using other extractors
and clouder has its own python package
called pi clouder so this is the way how
you can install Pi Cloud Pi clouder
provides you an easier way to talk to
the clouder service
so here I highlighted some of the
examples how we use Pi clutter in our
code for example we use it for file
upload and we can also use it to write
the output metadata and register it as
metadata to Cloud it's just like very
simple one liner and
you have everything and for more details
you can click this link
and
here is a um here is our clouder
instance for the social media microscope
project this might require registration
so if you register we will approve you
being like 48 hours
and because again I don't trust live
demo
so I recorded a quick two minute
demo on clouder
so this is the Crowder interface now you
can log in you can also click the sign
up
if you don't already have account
and after you're logging this shows you
all the activities you have recently
and here
um the drop down are showing a few
shortcuts but this is the main interface
this is the data sets these are all the
data sets you have access to
and if you click one of the data sets
this shows you all the files belong to
these data sets
and this is another way to see your own
space space is a way that you can manage
Access Control
and data set and collection and those
things
so now we're trying to create a brand
new data set
yep
and after that you can upload files so
here I have Elon musk's tweets
script from I don't know like at least
30 days ago
um so I'm just gonna import that
and for a lot of users this is already
enough they just want a place to store
their data and on this interface you can
see there are a lot of ways you can tag
the data you can share with a certain
person or you can add your own custom
metadata
next I want to show you how to submit
the data this CSV to the same smile
extractors
so here are the list of exact extractors
available for this instance so on the
top are some of the generic ones that I
enabled that help you to quickly preview
audio or get a file Digest
and moving down
um everything that starts with smm is
the smile customized extractors
and what will happen
okay so here
um I find the sentiment analysis
the computers
so here I find the sentiment and assets
you can decide which column you want to
analyze if you have multiple columns and
here I select the same Invader algorithm
and I click submit
and then on the data set
you can see the process it gives you
spin out all the logs and once this is
done
um I I programmed this extractor to
write the output right next to your data
set right next to your file in the same
data set so now you have all the outputs
deposited in the clouder and this is the
same pie chart
that you see
and here are some of the other model
outputs
and you can download them this way
okay
and for future plans
um we get a lot of requests to ask us to
write a python Library a client library
that we can use to interact with smm
apps because a lot of researchers are
getting more comfortable with
python as well as Jupiter so I think
this definitely is our list it could be
beneficial if we can provide them some
Jupiter notebook examples to do like
social media data retrieval or to batch
submitting to analysis or batch
downloading without using the interface
and next we are always on the look for a
good open source python libraries that
we can incorporate and if you have any
idea in your mind and don't hesitate to
reach out to us and lastly is um this
year the with the chai GPT and large
language modeling on the horizon we're
like equally looking into how we can
incorporate AI facilitated knowledge
Discovery with social media data and
yeah we're open to any kind of ideas and
I'd like to thank the NCSA cbdr fund we
largely support this activities and I
like to give some shout out to a few
crucial people at the center who gave us
invaluable support during the year and
help us spread the news about this tool
yeah and this is the resource you can
email us and visit us and read more
about us here and thank you so much yeah
any questions or yes
well this light sure
yes yes I think so
[Music]
um
yes
um this project
um yes this project is supported by the
national Center for super cupcake
application which is affiliated with the
university yeah
also on open source yes foreign
[Music]
yeah
and it's limited
exactly so in this project
I
mean yes
actually
um we have to register our app as a
client with Twitter now X and then
um you're just using your own credential
but your your limitation is tied to our
app
yeah and and this year I um
Twitter since it become X it has a
drastically changed their paid plans so
we're actually in the investigation of
like how much we can so yeah right now
the basic plan is like a 100 per month
and you will get for the app not for
each user for aggregated every user who
uses app you will only get about 10K
tweets which is minimum comparing to a
few years ago so we're actively locating
through that
um we have a few ideas that actually so
either for researcher who want to get
more data we can Outsource that to them
they can register their clients and to
they just need to give us their secret
their like a token password and then we
can connect a smile with their
credentials or we're actively actually
looking at other things like meta and
Instagram and Tick Tock yeah
you know thank you thank you for your
question
thank you everybody for attending uh
I break up this excellent dialogue
happen here we can continue it
in the hallway if it enters here
[Music]